hey this is presh talwalkar
the function f of x is differentiable
continuous and f of x is not equal to
zero for all values of x in the interval
four to eight
if f of four is equal to one over four f
of eight is equal to one over two
and the integral from four to eight of f
prime of x squared divided by f of x to
the fourth power is equal to one
what is the value of f of six equal to
this is one of the hardest problems that
was given in a test in vietnam
i think nuen huen koi for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
to solve this problem we are going to
solve for the function f of x
let's consider the integral from 4 to 8
of f prime of x divided by f of x
squared
we can solve this by means of u
substitution suppose u is equal to f x
then d u is equal to f prime of x dx
so this integral becomes the integral
from four to eight of d u over u squared
which is equal to negative one over u
from four to eight
we substitute and then simplify
we know the values of f of 8 and f of 4.
so we substitute in and we get that this
integral is equal to negative 2 plus 4
which is equal to 2.
from here
let's consider the square of f prime of
x divided by f of x squared plus k for
some constant k
we can expand this binomial
now let's take the integral of both
sides from 4 to 8.
the integral of a sum is the sum of the
integrals
we can then take the constant terms
outside of the integral
now let's compute these three integrals
we are given the value of the first
integral that's equal to one
we just computed the value of the second
integral that's equal to two
the value of the third integral is equal
to eight minus four which is equal to
four
so we'll substitute in and then we'll
simplify
one plus four k plus four k squared is
exactly equal to the square of two k
plus one
now let's pick a special value of k
let's let k be equal to negative one
over two
this means two k plus one will be equal
to 0.
so we substitute in
now what can we deduce
we know the square of any real valued
function will be non-negative
but we have that this integral is equal
to zero exactly
this is only possible if the integrand
is identically equal to zero
we can then take the square root of both
sides and then add one half to both
sides so we get f prime of x over the
square of f of x is equal to one over
two
we will now take the integral of both
sides
the left hand side will be negative one
over f of x and the right hand side
becomes x over two plus c
we substitute x is equal to four
and we can solve for the value of c
c will be equal to negative six
so we have negative one over f of x is
equal to x over two minus 6.
we then simplify the right hand side
then we can take the reciprocal of both
sides
then we multiply both sides by negative
1. so we solve that f x is equal to two
divided by twelve minus x
we just substitute x is equal to six so
we get f of six is equal to two over
twelve minus six
that's equal to two over six which
simplifies to be one over three
and that's the answer
what an interesting question
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]